wochen in deinem undine immer trockene
brötchen mit aufs klo
sie will die wc ente wird leute was geht
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen folge
von der komplex bekommen auf dem kanal
von crafter denn mitarbeiter der liebe
kommt crafter und das kriegt er die
bekommen hat sie gedacht gut wenn ich
irgendwie zu gast bin dann nämlich ist
ja dass in meinem kanal hoch und ich
habe gesagt nein aber es macht trotzdem
freunde wird aber wieder ertragen
spaß beiseite ich finde ganz schön
unnütz ja wir schon oben seht haben wir
uns heute mit blondinenwitze beschäftigt
und man doch immer wenn du ihn
vielleicht im titel jeden fall bis heute
mit platinen wie zu beschäftigen und da
kommt dass ein lustiger charakter ist
darf der heute den ersten witz vorlesen
nur scheiß wird so das muss ich noch mal
vorhersagen
das ist eine webseite und der witz heiße
blondinen wird 659 wissen also was macht
man wenn eine blondine eine handgranate
nach einem wird man zieht der regen
lässt aufnahmetest zwei minuten qualität
ist das a und o
eine blondine auf dem gymnasium ins bad
ging fand ich einschusslöcher im spiegel
anschauen wollte meine blonde schwester
selbstmord begehen
eine halbe stunde nach mitternacht und
einfach so einen scheiß alter mutter
gelesen warum schüttet eine blondine
wasser über die computertastatur
sie wollte auch mal im internet surfe
ich gesagt ich bin okay stellt sich eine
blondine morgen als erstes vor sie
wichtiger schwerer form und watte packt
mach du den nächsten witz ich hab heute
einfach ein wenig lust sich trotzdem so
jung aus los ist und ihnen ein loch
klagte sie ist es dunkel dort unten sie
antwortete ich weiß nicht gar nicht
sehen
einfach genau du warum die blondine
immer eine leiter mit wenn die zum
einkaufen geht weil die preise so hoch
okay was man eine blondine wenn sie mal
zu viel wasser gekocht hat ganz einfach
sie früher einmal kochens wasser kann
man immer gebrauchen
ich bin was der unterschied einer kapsel
in einer von einer katze einer blondine
ich weiß ich weiß es aber ich wusste
dass auch eine katze ganz sicher okay
dann nicht mehr an sagt dass eine lebt
auf allen vieren und streckte meistens
sei ein arschloch genüsslich entgegen
dass andere es heute könnte man eine
blondine am computer wenn es brennt sie
drückt auf löschen
die figuren sind nötige beladen kuchen
zu backen fünf stück eine macht den teig
und die anderen vier stellen die
smarties nach münchen um 1810 mit
digitale geräte stuhl brezel
es war einfach nicht lustig mein gott
was hat eine blondine die einen
strohballen hinter sich her zieht er ist
erreicht reich besserwissen blondine
schenk mein kind der mann geschenkt man
nicht sie werden geboren blondine ja
dann bei mir 1
eine blondine immer trockene brötchen
mit aufs klo wcm twitter dementiert dass
du deine mutter wissen nicht an die wand
lehnen eine klügere nachgibt
eine blondine hat zwei gehirnzellen
schwanger ist eine blondine abtreibung
sicher zu gehen ob das kind überhaupt
von ok was 100 von ihnen auf dem
meeresgrund ein anfang
lukas hast du ein rückpass auf welches
das einzige fremdwort das eine problem
kennt aktiv sind nicht zu groß sein und
jane blond werden ich war noch nie was
wäre dann der affe schreibt bitte alle
hätten
warum ist eine blondine stolz weil sie
ein puzzle in vier monaten fertig stellt
das update nicht kennt weil auf der
packung steht drei bis vier jahre
rücklicht geht linker geht geht nicht
geht geht nicht 19 und einen flachen
kopf damit warum stellt die blondine
ihren computer auf den boden damit er
nicht wichtig ja natürlich
was lässt sich ein porsche und einer
blondine forscher verleiht man halt
nicht an freunde
was tun blondinen wenn sie hören dass 90
prozent aller unfälle in einer wohnung
stattfinden
umziehen der abi nicht der gesellschaft
man eben das mutterschaf auch beim
versuch die schamhaare verbrannt keine
bse willkommen bei wenigen krankheit ist
eine blondine die fallschirmspringen
wenn sie ihre tage hat sie könnte das
falsche benzin ist okay loukas louka
steckt sich currywurst und ihre mutter
rose stattfand 100 weil ich habe 100
marken ok wenn ihr doch finde dass ich
wieder meine daumen hoch da und
schreiben konnte ich der kondom kopf in
die kommentare
das was von diesem video auf jeden fall
wally und lukas vorbei aber auch bei
mister x games und da kann man ja mal
sagen oder
und das war für dieses video